julie garnier qui est oratrice la france
insoumise candidate aux élections
régionales en ile-de-france bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous alors d'abord
votre commentaire concernant le grand
gagnant finalement de ces élections
c'est l'abstention 66% l'estimation à 20
heures alors je sais pas si on peut
parler de gagnants en tout cas on peut
tout de suite considéré qu'il y a quand
même un chaos démocratique et que
aujourd'hui notre démocratie on la
considérait déjà comme défaillante
aujourd'hui elle est en soins palliatifs
et ça je crois que c'est un constat
qu'on peut tous le faire tous faire et
du coup forcément ça doit forcer à
l'humilité c'est à dire que ceux qui
proclament qu'ils ont gagné doivent
regarder avec quoi quel pourcentage
d'inscrits ils ont gagné aujourd'hui on
doit se poser la question est pas versée
comme trop souvent des larmes de
crocodile et le lendemain passer à un
autre sujet je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
faisons des propositions très concrètes
sur comment est-ce qu'on peut redonner
confiance en la politique
nous proposons depuis des années la 6ème
république nous nous mettons sur la
table et nous ne cessons de vouloir le
mettre en débat et personne ne nous
répond là dessus personne ne nous dit
est ce que oui ou non vous êtes d'accord
avec la reconnaissance du vote blanc est
ce que oui ou non vous êtes d'accord
avec le référendum révocatoire avec le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne est ce
que oui ou non vous êtes d'accord avec
un seuil minimal pour que les élections
soient valides et cetera et cetera
ces propositions elles sont nombreuses
nous les mettons sur la table et nous
n'attendons qu'une seule chose c'est
qu'elle soit discutée
alors un commentaire concernant les
l'issue en dés
de ces élections les résultats partiels
en tout cas cinq régions qui vont au ps
ses alliés comment tel est votre lecture
la pompe que c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile d'avoir une analyse
quand aussi peu de personnes se sont
exprimées et je crois que la première
analyse
on ne peut pas passer à côté de ça il
faut quand même se le redire ce premier
tour pour revenir à celui ci a été le
plus gros taux d'abstention de la vème
république
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de plus pour
que pour salir tu es là dessus on attend
quoi on attend encore un taux encore
plus bas on attend quoi
et dès ce second tour alors qu'on aurait
pu espérer à un regain démocratique il
n'y a pas eu de vrai regard il n'y a pas
eu de vrai de vrai sursaut démocratique
aujourd'hui la question qu'il faut qu'on
se pose c'est celle ci et si demain je
suis élu moi je me poserai la question
sincèrement qu est ce que je pourrais
faire qu'est ce qu'on pourra faire pour
que les personnes puissent revenir dans
les yeux revenir vers la confiance dans
la politique je crois que tout politique
aujourd'hui devrait d'abord répondre à
cette question là avant de fêter quoi
que ce soit mais vous voyez les vous
avez entendu probablement est suivi de
près les déclarations des candidats on
en a parlé en durant toute cette édition
spéciale par exemple
julien bayou l'écologiste lui avec la
veille que l'écologie était la seule
force en dynamique
comment vous accueillez vous cette
déclaration et cette posture
je crois que malheureusement les choses
serait simple si on vous les lisez comme
ça mais je crois d un peu compliqué
c'est à dire que vraiment il faut
regarder dans quel océan d'abstention
nous sommes il ya une dynamique
peut-être mais je crois surtout que ce
qui ce qui fait aujourd'hui gagner c'est
c'est l'union mais l'union elle ne fait
pas non plus déplacé les foules et on
peut se poser la question de caisse qui
doit déplacer les foules aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on peut se sentir
à nouveau dans une démocratie qui
fonctionne la question elle est là
foncièrement elle est là et je crois que
tant qu'on ne répondra pas à ces
questions là alors nous passerons à côté
et nous ferons que répéter les mêmes
erreurs c'est à dire refaire des
élections avec une abstention de plus en
plus forte
vraiment il n'ya pas de quoi fanfaronner
ce soir je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment se poser les questions et moi
je n'attend qu'une seule chose c'est
qu'on mette véritablement sur la table
des propositions très concrètes
je le dis et le redis la 6ème république
pour nous est une solution
le fait que les ceux qui sont élus n'est
plus de chèque en blanc est soit
redevable c'est à dire qu'on est des
responsables politiques qui soit
responsable
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas ça on se
souvient d'entendre gelé garnier lima
rosicky et au qg de valérie pécresse
face à elle il ya une union donc de la
gauche un mené par l'écologie julien
bayou avec clémentine autain audrey
pulvar pour le ps clémentine autain pour
la france insoumise le bilan de cette
stratégie d'alliance le bilan il est que
nous n'avons pas réussi à prendre la
région ça c'est un fait mais je crois
que le bilan il est d'abord du côté de
l'abstention je le redis vous savez j'ai
fait le tour aujourd'hui un peu du
département de la seine-et-marne et ce
que j'ai constaté c'est que des
personnes n'avaient pas reçu les
professions de foi les perdre toutes les
personnes n'avaient pas reçu tous les
documents officiels qui font qu'une
démocratique et fonctionne je l' ai
gagnée par un peu facile
se cacher derrière ce taux d'abstention
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup pénalisés ce
soir mais la question elle était quand
même précise le bilan vous faites de la
stratégie d'alliances monnaies face à
valérie pécresse qui n'a pas fonctionné
je voulais je voulais dit je le redis je
pense que honnêtement
l'abstention ne ce n'est pas se cacher
c'est justement tous les autres qui font
déjà en 2022 qui eux se cache derrière
ce résultat il faut vraiment pas
inverser les choses
ceux qui aujourd'hui minimise le plus
gros impact de ces élections ce sont
ceux déjà qu'il pense aux
présidentielles et à leur propre
carrière politique
et c'est bien ça le problème aujourd'hui
en politique et donc non justement le
fait de parler de l'abstention ce n'est
absolument pas se cacher c'est au
contraire prendre le problème tel qu'il
est c'est à dire extrêmement
sérieusement et j'aimerais que les
politiques le fasse et aujourd'hui
malheureusement ils ne le font pas et il
me met aucune proposition sur la table
vous voyez dans votre reportage dans
xavier bertrand les les militants qu'il
avait autour de lui qui disait il saura
rassembler les français déjà dit le ce
sont des militants que vous avez
interviewé et non pas des personnes qui
se sont abstenus et moi j'aimerais
justement qu'on donne la parole à ces
personnes qui se sont abstenus et je
vous assure que l aile minimiserait
complètement l'impact du il saura il
fera et quoi que ce soit je te dis sans
justement j'ai les guerriers pour
ajustements concernant tous ces votants
potentiels qui se sont abstenus il ya
une raison à cela
on parle beaucoup de défiance vis-à-vis
de la classe politique et cela vaut
concerne aussi des bien sûr mais
malheureusement moi ce que j'attends
c'est que justement de mettions sur la
table des propositions pour affronter
ceux ci et affronter ce bilan
aujourd'hui quand on a des politiques
qui font des larmes de crocodile le soir
et le lendemain sont déjà dans les
stratégies politiciennes et bien je ne
suis désolé ne tire aucun bilan
les seuls qui tire des bilans et qui
font des propositions jusqu alors c'est
quand nous parlons de 6ème république
quand nous parlons du vote blanc quand
nous parlons des référendum révocatoire
ça ce sont des propositions mais qui
d'autre en parle aujourd'hui ce soir qui
d'autre diplômant qui d'autre donc gelé
garnier la l'union des gauches qui
pourrait être tenir la route si la
présidentielle vous n'y croyez pas je
crois surtout que ce qu'il faut c'est
surtout redonner confiance et que une
union il faut
d'abord qu'elle donne envie avant de
juste l'union pour l'union ne fait pas
déplacé les foules c'est une évidence
par contre se mettre autour d'un vrai
projet d'une vième république d'une
règle verte d'un minimum de dignité pour
tout le monde ça je pense que oui ça
peut faire bouger les choses et tant qu'
on ne mettra pas ces sujets là sur la
table
je crois que on passera à chaque fois à
côté du sujet mais les délais sont assez
courts 1 d'ici la prochaine échéance la
présidentielle pour justement mener
toutes les réformes auxquelles vous
faites allusion et on sait très bien
qu'au sein de la gauche aujourd'hui ces
deux défis dès aujourd'hui un leadership
en vue de cette présidentielle il ya
aussi des polémiques un niveau d'aidé
des alliances au sein de la gauche deux
du parti et des écologistes jusqu'à la
france insoumise
alors autant pour moi mais je pense que
le leadership
il existe déjà à gauche hein et puis je
pense qu' aucun sondage n'a d'ailleurs
réussi à démontrer que la personne qui
pouvait jusqu'à lors mieux incarner
justement cette 6ème république ce
minimum de dignité cette règle verte
cette vision écologiste et planification
etc
c'est jean luc mélenchon et ça ce sont
les sondages qui me disent maintenant la
question c'est de savoir est ce que
justement ces personnes sont prêtes à se
fédérer autour de ce programme là parce
que la question est elle est la suivante
c'est qu'est ce que nous voulons comme à
venir pour demain quelles sont les
solutions dont nous voulons parler c'est
ça le sujet aujourd'hui des fonds d'âge
est ce qu'on peut vraiment je veux dire
se fier aujourd'hui aux sondages parce
que c'est vrai que la lecture qui était
donnée avant ces élections
départementales et régionales là on voit
bien que finalement ça va à
contre-courant on n'est pas du tout dans
les les
les pronostics qui était donné et c'est
à dire ce duel rassemblement national
l'as raismes
ah bah ça c'est sûr que tout ce qu'il me
disait que ce serait un second tour lrm
rassemblement national sont bien dépité
ça c'est une évidence mais là vous
parler d'un autre sujet à elles vont
parler d'un sujet national et savoir ce
qu'il y aura pour demain moi je vous
parle de quelle union pour la gauche
unie autour de quel projet c'est pas la
même question sur la question moi je ce
que je vous dise que je mets sur la
table c'est la 6ème république ce sont
toutes les propositions dont
malheureusement le traitement médiatique
n'a jamais été à la hauteur jusque là et
ça je crois aussi que c'est un
enseignement qu'on doit tirer c'est
regarder tous les sujets qu'on nous a
imposée et fait subir sur les plateaux
télé et regarder quelles sont quelle est
la réalité aujourd'hui des résultats est
bien c'est que les sujets qui ont été
mises en avant
et à chaque fois les acteurs qu on nous
mettait en avant ne se retrouve pas dans
les yeux risque pour certifier à peu
près de jean luc mélenchon vous pensez
qu'ils peuvent fédérer justement une
union en vue de la présidentielle parce
qu'on sait qu'il fait pas forcément il
ya des petites tensions avec notamment
anne hidalgo qui ne cache pas ses
ambitions à même si elle a soutenu
évidemment le front gauche là pour ces
élections
aujourd'hui c'est c'est pas une question
de personnalité c'est une question de
projet à gauche vous avez deux
idéologies qui s'affrontent
vous avez une gauche qui veut
accompagner le capitalisme qui a voté
toutes les tous les traités de libre
échange etc et vous avez une gauche qui
elle veut justement être une gauche de
rupture
une gauche qui défend justement la règle
verte qui défend une nouvelle république
qui défend des institutions qui défend
les services publics qui défend la
solidarité qui voient les choses de
manière complètement différente
et aujourd'hui la gauche et les
traversées par ce courant là est la
question est de savoir au delà de la
personne sait quel projet nous allons
défendre et quelle gauche nous voulons
mettre en avant c'est ça vous pouvez pas
regarder l'union parce que vous ne
pouvez pas faire l'union entre les
personnes qui veulent accompagner le
capitalisme et le libéralisme et des
personnes qui veulent prendre au sérieux
le changement climatique la question à
elle est là et aujourd'hui celui qui
incarne le mieux la possibilité
de pouvoir justement redonner de la
place à l'intérêt général
et bien c'est jean luc mélenchon tout
simplement et c'est lui qui il ya le
projet pour terminer rapidement le
commentaire justement sur la victoire
selon toujours les résultats partiels de
valérie pécresse en ile de france mais
aussi cette vague bleue dans dans les
régions qu'on a qu'on considère un peu
comme les régions phares de ces
élections les hôtes france ile de france
et la propre provence alpes côte d'azur
excusez moi ça a coupé je suis désolé je
n'en pense je veux demander rapidement
un commentaire sur la victoire de
valérie pécresse mais aussi celle de
xavier bertrand dans les hauts de france
2 laurent wauquiez aussi en auvergne
rhône-alpes et celle de renaud muselier
en paca n'a vous voilez moi ma première
pensée elle va d'abord pour tous ces
services publics qui vont être
privatisées je pense à la ratp à la sncf
qui vont subir les prochaines années la
privatisation et à tous ses usagers
pardon à qui il faudra expliquer que
maintenant c'est l'intérêt des
actionnaires qui va passer avant
l'intérêt des usagers est vraiment j'ai
mal au coeur pour ça parce que ceux qui
vont trinquer encore ce sont tous ceux
qui sont éloignés des centres villes
tous ceux qui sont loin dans la grande
couronne dans les quartiers populaires
ce sont eux qui vont trinquer en premier
et vraiment il va falloir leur dire il
va falloir tenir bon parce que la
légitimité malheureusement elle est
quand même assez maigre quand on est élu
avec à peine quelques pourcentages des
inscrits merci beaucoup à vous je lis
garnier oratrice de la france insoumise
candidate aller sinon qu raison aux
régionales en île de france merci à vous